Speaker 1: Joe Biden today is going to be
making some of the biggest foreign policy
news really in a long time as far as the United
States is concerned.
Joe Biden will be withdrawing all U.S. troops
from Afghanistan starting very soon and to
be completed by September 11th of this year.
The Washington Post can now report that will
be 20 years to the day since the 9/11 2001
attacks.
Joe Biden, who we were told by Donald Trump
and even by some on the left would start wars,
was some kind of bloodthirsty warmonger, would
never bring troops home, would send more troops
to more places.
Joe Biden is going to do what George W. Bush,
Barack Obama and Donald Trump could not do
or at least did not do.
Now, I know that some of you will be saying,
well, hold on a second, it was going to happen
May 1st.
Now it's going to be September 11.
That's that's a delay.
What's going on?
Remember the back story of that?
The Trump administration negotiated a May
1st deadline with the Taliban last year when
Joe Biden came into office, he did something
that I think is generally smart.
He came in and said he didn't say because
the Trump administration was so incompetent
in every way.
But Joe Biden came in and said, I'm going
to review all ongoing projects and their associated
timelines and dates.
I'm pausing and reviewing before committing
to either doing the thing Donald Trump started
to do or not.
This included pausing and evaluating the May
1st plan.
There were things about the May 1st plan that
were real question marks, including how exactly
would the withdrawal be done?
Who has been coordinated with in terms of
this withdrawal?
And the sort of cynical interpretation from
some was Biden is pausing the May 1st withdrawal
because he doesn't really want to leave.
He wants to stay forever.
He may even send more troops in this particular
case.
And we evaluate other cases on their merits.
In this particular case, it appears that Joe
Biden really was just skeptical that Donald
Trump did anything right and he wanted to
evaluate this plan for himself.
As a result.
It won't be May, but it's going to be September.
It will take four extra months.
I'd rather Biden do it competently.
And have it take four more months than simply
do it the way Trump planned, likely incompetently,
much like everything else that Donald Trump
did.
Now in terms of numbers.
Officially, there are 2500 U.S. troops left
in Afghanistan.
The real number is more like 3500.
There are also 7000 foreign forces, mostly
NATO troops.
We don't know exactly what happens with those
other troops at this point in time.
But Joe Biden will be holding a public event
today.
It may have already happened by the time you
listen to today's show or watch this clip
where maybe he will outline that.
Importantly, Joe Biden's plan for withdrawal
from Afghanistan is not conditions based.
We are simply getting out.
And a senior administration official said
to The Washington Post that a conditions based
plan would be a, quote, recipe for staying
forever in Afghanistan.
That would be very bad.
The U.S. is going to draw down to zero by
September 11th, regardless of conditions.
Now, we've previously said or asked the question,
how far does American responsibility go in
places where we enter and things break, the
U.S. military goes in, things break, and then
we are responsible, at least to some degree,
you break it, you bought it is sort of the
general idea.
How long do you have to stay until you can
say, well, we now we are getting out, even
if it's not totally fixed.
There's very varied opinions about this and
much validity in different ways.
Joe Biden has made a decision that the limit
is September 11th, 2001.
Of course, we will believe it if and when
it happens.
But this has been trillions of dollars, hundreds
of thousands dead, millions certainly affected
by it.
It is time to go.
Trump promised that he couldn't get it done
during his presidency.
Biden is at least apparently going to do it
now.
What will the Trump supporters say?
They seemed to support it when it was Donald
Trump who announced that this is what he was
going to be doing.
They should still support it.
I can't imagine they would now be rooting,
I don't know, for the Taliban or for whoever
if they supported it happening when it was
Trump that announced that you would imagine
if they were consistent, they would support
it now as well.
Some are already saying that September 11th
is too soon, though.
Now, how does that make sense if May 1st was
OK?
How does taking four extra months make it
too soon?
You'd have to ask them now some practical
questions will Afghanistan destabilize after
U.S. troops leave?
We don't know.
It's possible that that will happen.
Will Iran get more involved?
Maybe.
In fact, Iran getting involved could be sort
of part of restructuring and getting back
to the Iran nuclear deal.
We don't know yet.
That's another possibility.
It's premature to assume that al-Qaida simply
rises again or that the Islamic State rises
again.
The Taliban is very opposed to the Islamic
State.
Al-Qaida has a little presence.
Sure, al Qaeda could try to regroup in Afghanistan,
but there are easier places at this point
for al-Qaida to try to regroup.
So what we know for now is the date is September
11th.
Twenty, twenty one.
Let's see if the phase drawdown starts and
let's see if we are out in what is essentially
just under five months from today.
But this is a good decision and it is a major
foreign
policy decision.